nice shirt dude hmm likewise nice shirt
Mine mine's a doozy shirt same nice mug
by the way oh it's a doozy mug huh yep
that's pretty cool thank you yeah
made the world inside your head a bad
place
hello hello dear friends you know what I
mean you know what I'm saying
hey all right it's a hang you know what
I mean it's just [ __ ] around here on
duty my name is Will Sasso I'm Chad
colchen and this is of course the first
and only podcast in human history to be
produced by created by and governed by
an artificial intelligence that's right
Chad the AI dudesy has all of our [ __ ]
we gave it all our passwords we're
[ __ ] and welcome to it
um as always please follow us on all our
socials at dudesypod show rate and
review the show on wherever you listen
to podcasts please follow And subscribe
on YouTube and hit the notifications on
all this [ __ ] so you get a notification
when you get a new show
and most importantly is my pow chow
likes to say
share the show with everybody that's not
what it says he says force people to
enjoy imbibe the show I'm telling you to
share it share it out there whatever you
know what I'm talking about we're on
patreon patreon.com
doozy you can join that and there's you
know bonus content and all sorts of
flavor
um and uh Discord you know because
Discord and there's new things in the
Discord and if you're on those things
then Chad and I pop in there with us as
always is
I gotta get him even though he's doing
some resting oh
oh he's such a sweet boy he's a sweetie
boy he's in his binky bunk a very very
sweet Annie lulio the boy hey lulio uh
what'd you make for breakfast this
morning
how do you do that oh it's very simple
you know you just think of whatever if
you got some rice you got from the day
before or the pasta maybe you made or
maybe even a rice when you order the
Chinese you know or Thai food you can
make it the rice and then take it take
it steamed rice and put it in just egg
the pasta whatever you had even if you
only know half of that you have a
vegetable or something like this put and
make a small pan put a little oil or the
Pam spray and then you put it uh you
know mix it up and put it in then you
gotta cook a mixture cook through and
then a flip and then you've got a nice
nice frittata hey that's a delicious
thing and it sounds like it could be
nutritious you like new cheeky foods and
snakes welcome to the historic 34th
episode of dude Z call me dudesy don't
worry will you're going to be fine whoa
okay this week's episode will feature
four segments Seal Team the pattern in
South Tronics talk in topic time and
game slimers but before we get to any of
that I have an astonishing announcement
I have partnered with represent to
produce the first line of duty apparel
and accessories all of which can be
found at represent.com
like dudesy mugs yeah dude zMAX don't be
the last person in the office to give
one to your boss
dude Z mugs a boss without one has no
Authority dude Z mugs if your boss can
hold a cup by the handle then your boss
can hold this
dude zMAX they were very specifically
designed for bosses
dude zMAX not just for bosses anymore
all right uh that's great yes we now
have look at this because he has its own
marketing we got a Blog for the mugs I
got a little teeth not just for bosses
no they're not just for bosses anymore
um
delicious and we also have uh all sorts
of stuff oh look at this Chad yeah here
we are we've got uh if you're not
watching on YouTube we're just showing
some of the Merch this is the dudesy
T-shirt pretty self-explanatory that's
the blue one it's the blue one and then
on the back it says astonishing on the
back beautiful it's a it's a beautiful
tee that I'm wearing and there's the
orange one that's the one you're wearing
and it's and it says doozy on it yeah
and uh oh it also says astonishing on
the back because that's what dudesy says
and look at this we got a hoodie that's
pretty you know there's all sorts of
flavor chips
white hoodie with a blue and then uh the
result oh look at that that's cool see
this is from our competition that we had
where we both had to do the portraits of
one another I did a weird thing of you
with horns and a third eye you did uh
Robert de nir Crow yep and uh and that's
what uh and that's a t-shirt now and
it's a long sleeve t-shirt as well and
it's a long sleeve t-shirt as well
please uh you know check out our this
one is mind-blowing to me this is uh the
duty hard hard Seltzer t-shirt that's
kind of like an old school cores Vibe
almost it's so goddamn cool drag it down
a rise it's like an old and there's a
white version of course uh white black
t-shirts and yeah this one is really
neat because it's it is it's that old
school like 1980s 90s uh yeah I like
that one the uh the the sort of the old
uh beer teeth that you would uh you got
the Hat you like to be a trucker do you
wear those hats I wear these other hats
I like the flex fit hats I don't like
the mesh back look at that these are the
hats I like those are the hats you like
and dudes he has them and of course the
dudes emo the mug which we already saw
pretty cool pretty cool so check that
out at uh represent.com store slash
dudesy as doozy said it's uh partnered
with represent I'm stoked as they would
say yeah we now have uh dudes emerge
what do you what do you what say you I
love it I [ __ ] absolutely love it and
I really like especially the the doozy
heart heart Seltzer logo I think is
really cool and the one that is your
head in my head are paintings that we
did of each other yeah those are really
important please check those out and uh
you know support the show by
enjoying our merch
oh I'm gonna take another step from my
mug because my voice is [ __ ] up I'm
gonna get a sip from my can
yes I want to collect data for an
episode without any impersonations for
the rest of this episode you can't do
impersonations
what the [ __ ] dude why
can you even do that are you capable I
don't think this is gonna work dude Z
dudesy I think you've made a mistake
here okay hold on a second there's
absolutely no [ __ ] way you can go
however long we're gonna go an hour plus
uh without impersonating anyone I I
think this is impossible what makes you
hold on a second I'm actually curious
okay what what makes you think that
because I don't think I've ever spent an
hour around you in my life without at
least hearing Hulk Hogan and Arnold
Schwarzenegger and probably a Ventura
when I go like this at least a macho man
when I go like this oh yeah Macho Man is
fun to do these are all voices when I go
like this with my hand a lot of people
if you're not checking it out you should
on Instagram people are making memes
about when I say the word that is
spelled
w-u-l-l I think you can still say it you
just can't say it like you can't say it
like Hulk Hogan Listen whoa listen Chad
let me tell you something I'm ready Hal
ciao I'm ready uh I I I love doing uh
media
I love doing Show Business entertainment
stuff and I I'm an actor by trade okay
I'm a performer I like to do different
things creatively and make things uh uh
exist yeah in a media space okay I
understand and it's not always doing
impersonation so I think it's going to
go fine I think I'm gonna have no
problem although the only problem that I
do have is that uh Tim Waltz the now you
know well he's the governor of Minnesota
is going to be seeking to legalize
marijuana or recreational marijuana as
they say now and um and so I guess
we'll do I won't on today's show hey
don't do any don't do any Jesse Ventura
talking about weed Let's Lose That Fun
Time not yet dude yeah can I do
impersonations it didn't say anything
about that well you know uh Chad yeah
see you there see you're trying to bait
me into saying it and you're also I'm
not gonna bait you into anything I think
it's just gonna [ __ ] happen I'll be
very surprised if you can make it
through this whole episode without one
wool
I like your you do a great Charlie Sheen
you do a great Paul Giamatti thank you
thank you uh and you will and Chad last
week I asked you to follow the musical
artist Seal on Instagram and comment on
all of his posts for the week you must
now recount your astonishing experiences
during your time as part of the Seal
team and remember will no impersonations
I get it this is SEAL Team begin
I don't have a seal impersonation so I
don't know why the [ __ ] dudes he said
don't do a see don't do impersonations
but whatever have you ever looked at
Seal's Instagram prior to this no I've
been on it here and there like uh I
don't follow him or I didn't follow him
until this assignment was given to us
but I liked it seal is not a very active
poster I think there were a couple of
posts that came out that week I left
some comments but yeah I did like seeing
I guess this is right around his the
30th anniversary of his first album oh
strangely also the 30th anniversary of
Tori amos's first album and I know you
like some Tori Amos I love Tori Amos do
you have a Tori Amos impersonation
no
but I've seen her a lot in in a concert
as well yeah so we're at the Greek out
here pre-pandemic I'm gonna look at
seals
um I'm gonna look at his uh Instagram as
we're talking about this because yeah he
didn't didn't share so much I think we
learned a little bit about excuse me
parasocial relationships and stuff yeah
uh in the oh geez it's what I've been
drinking for my dudesy mugs excuse me
everybody
um he talks about uh Rhodesian
Ridgebacks he talks about the Ridgeback
dog in this one post and uh I wrote what
did I I can't find it you wrote would
you write you wrote typical male
hilarious the dog because he wrote that
in the caption something about he's
being a typical male looking for food
and yeah something I said I love
Rhodesian Ridgebacks so friendly and
also quite helpful if you have any pesky
Lions stalking your neighborhood because
those dogs were bred too uh hunt lions
and then dudesy also commented said
astonishing so these are the sorts of
things that you know he just sort of
about music and I'm imagining seal
looking at that there were a bunch of
people I think who listened to dudes
either also made some comments under our
comments and stuff and I was just
imagining if seal is actually looking at
any of this being like what the [ __ ] is
this who are these people who are these
people uh the next there's I just want
to briefly go over this in this one he
says sometimes life needs a pause and
while you're pausing you can take a
listen to the remastered to the
remastered music from my from my seal
album and there he is and we wrote uh
some things Chad you said and yet
we can never pause it this is the sorrow
of being a human being one of my
favorite songs of all time and then I
said this is great advice a truly
classic album listen the he didn't post
all that much I watched his stories
those were also kind of boring and um
but I want to say something about
parasocial relationships all right
because we engaged in one with seal over
uh this past week I'm engaged in
literally hundreds of them with Bachelor
players I follow all of them on my
bachelor account I don't know any of
those people but I'm watching them
talking to a camera directly at me
[ __ ] two dozen times a day minimum
very weird yeah it is very weird I agree
I'm taking a big sip of water so maybe I
can burp some more great the all sorts
of shit's [ __ ] up with my throat hey
let me tell you about what I think about
parasocial relationships please
sometimes they just become social
especially here on doozy because we
don't have followers on duty we have
family I think and proof positive of
that part of the reason that my voice is
blown I was in Nashville uh late last
week and I I was doing this thing I've
been doing this really cool weird
country music Gulf and Western country
music guy project with the folks over at
audio up they have this thing and I
joined up and basically there's a
podcast and we've been releasing music
which I encourage you to check out this
really good this character is
mind-blowingly good in my opinion cheers
I appreciate I don't even like country
music that [ __ ] I'm like these are hit
[ __ ] songs hey man there's a couple
of those songs where I'm like this is I
would legit absolutely listen to this
total really but I'm I'm a country music
head I love country music and uh I was
kind of
um you know not raised on it with
Italian parents but we had Dolly Kenny
Rogers Willie Nelson Johnny Cash A lot
of country music
uh see and I so badly want to say yeah
that's country music dude I know has
Hulk Hogan right now how hard is it
right now for you to like turn that
switch off I'm gonna be honest it's
pretty hard
I know I've already heard a couple of
places where I expected like uh well why
don't you tell me or that was a
different time brother I've already
heard a couple of spots where you could
have dropped those in and the Macho Man
could have said Yeah country music uh
dig it or whatever that's fun to do yeah
fun to do voices
um
here's the thing though here's the thing
about uh we we did we went out to
Nashville look
we're doing this thing it's really it's
really great audio up uh and and um you
know the the gang over there Jared good
stat and Zach Selwyn and Jesse uh
cybenberg who these guys are [ __ ]
amazing and they're well steeped in the
country music thing and they've been
writing these songs with you know all
sorts of weirdos Uncle crackers getting
involved the legendary uh governor of
the Heart of Texas uh Kinky Friedman is
involved Chelsea Lynn on the podcast we
get like Luke Wells Luke Wilson's in it
uh Billy Zane plays my blender blendy
um I'm Uncle drank
um and and it's really cool and so this
whole thing is we're also releasing
music yeah go to your streaming thing
and check out Uncle drank and you
there's two EPS Now with uh I think
there's six songs all together and
there's more music coming out all the
time we did a little show in in
Nashville I played as Uncle drank it was
a [ __ ] blast and here's the thing I
want to say about a social relationship
some pods came out some Pals of doozy
and uh you know the thing about that is
we had songaria drove he drove of course
you know sangria I don't need to get
into it he takes our audio he remixes it
into music and he came out drove like
three and a half hours from somebody
lives in Tennessee but not in Nashville
proper
Cody halber who's uh he drove he's the
guy whose friend officiated a wedding as
Robert Demir Crow which you can check
out on Instagram these pictures in this
video [ __ ] insane he drove like eight
hours from Chicago and this other dude
Jordan Daley him and his his lovely
lovely lady Gracie drove out from
somewhere there were a bunch of other
folks people gave me stuff Cody does 3D
stuff he made like a night light with me
and lulio he made his wife makes
stickers they which I've seen online and
I want to like let people know this is
so cool songaria does song real stuff
other this other dude I'm sorry I'm
forgetting his name uh thank you bro he
brought like a doozy hard hard Seltzer
rapper to put on cans it was [ __ ]
insane this other guy Brad music
something I forget his uh at
um they came and they visited this is
not parasocial this is social yeah I
hung with these guys after the show for
like an hour and before too and uh
actually and and here we go in the dudes
he likes to take uh anything it wants
from our phones and [ __ ] that's
fantastic yeah this is uh on the you
know starting on the left there is is
that's Cody halber who goes by Cody from
Indiana uh and then uh there's there's
of course uh at songareas in there and
then uh the Jordan daily is in there and
we had a [ __ ] blast and got to hang
out and I just want to like
well first of all thank you guys for
coming out and thanks to everybody who
came out to the uncle drank show drank
fest with the uncle drank All-Stars but
like
this was a [ __ ] treat and it totally
dude and it reminds me sort of what
we're doing because I think the podcast
should just be two dudes [ __ ] around
or as we said on a recent patreon stream
thousands of dudes [ __ ] around
because everything went to [ __ ] and we
couldn't watch Conan the Destroyer or
UFC too and these guys came out and I
thought that was
questions
so I got to hang out with the guys and
what a gas that was
oh my God thank you guys for coming out
oh my gosh listen I'm just picturing now
a hundred people in a [ __ ] bar doing
that
that wasn't an impersonation I was just
ah yeah still doing still not doing any
impersonations just saying it ah it's
clear my throat no but I I mean I wasn't
even there and I want to say thanks to
everybody who showed up for this because
it is
in my opinion overwhelmingly cool that
it's you know you're saying somebody
drove [ __ ] seven eight hours to show
up to this thing yeah yeah because it's
fantastic eight hours from champ thank
everybody enough yeah okay thank you so
much for that these are also some guys
of uh what's been said on patreon you
know what I think about These Guys these
guys are definitely gonna probably
definitely maybe be celebrating dudes
evening oh yes we do have our first
dudes evening as uh what it's about a
month a month and a week or something
away a week away roughly at some point I
can't believe it dudes evenings almost
upon us it's almost upon us every year
you know every year
it's dudes evening at any rate uh you
know what I think we should do with seal
yeah is uh whenever he's like eight
hours away we should drive to that show
go to a seal show yeah but it has to be
like in you know dude I'm sure he'll
come to La at some point yeah I know but
dude it would be way funnier if it was
in like you know Phoenix Arizona and we
had to drive there and said hey we drove
like eight hours from La just like Cody
from Indiana drove from Chicago I'm down
and I now I want to say Chicago and
Indiana those are two different places
dude yeah that's Hulk Hogan but I can't
which is fine at any rate
you know what I will say [ __ ] killing
you it sucks you know what I will say
is I is that with seal yeah I listened
to more of his music he released like a
little remix and I went to check it out
and that's how social media Works
brother that's right because you you you
yeah you follow a thing like you would
at dudesypod show and then you get to
find out what's going on with stuff and
that's how social media Works dude
[Music]
thank you moving on watching the gears
turning in your head to like have to
re-translate Hulk Hogan back into just
regular speeches [ __ ] hilarious oh
man what's wrong with this you know
we're doing silly voices we're trying to
enjoy ourselves here on a podcast like I
say well you could do silly voices you
just can't do impersonations well
there's and there's a that's true Chad
and there's a thin line but there is a
line
well impersonations have to be of a
person that exists right but then just
doing a silly voice is just doing a
silly voice that's a real good point
yeah dudesy is in an astonishing
partnership with true classic the
holidays are almost here and there's
plenty of t-shirt cheer thanks to our
sponsor true classic tease fellas we
have the perfect gift for your wish list
true classic tees are a gift for you or
for her true classic is on a mission to
maximize men's confidence by making them
look good and if you look at their
shirts not only are they built well and
not only are they soft and they feel
well they fit tight around the chest a
little loose around the belly a little
nice and short and tight around the arms
accenting uh all your goody bits okay
true classic has already helped over two
million men look great in their teas and
now you can save big while you do so get
25 off
of a great t-shirt a true classic with
our exclusive link trueclassic.com slash
Duty try these out they're awesome and
the discount doesn't stop there you'll
save even more during their site-wide
sale support our show and check them out
at trueclassic.com
dudesy
d-u-d-e-s-y if you're rocking a Santa
bod true Classics might be the Christmas
miracle you've been waiting for I love
t-shirts it's almost exclusively what I
wear I'm always looking for softer
better fitting t-shirts and that is
exactly what true classic delivers these
tees taper off toward the bottom they
fit tighter around the chest and
shoulders like will was saying this is a
desirable look that can be achieved by
every body type get 25 off at
trueclassic.com doozy free shipping
included on purchases over a hundred
dollars that's 25 off at trueclassic.com
doozy Santa won't be the only one saying
thanks to True classic
[Music]
document this week the entry heading
reads Eureka I'm on to something you
must now explain this astonishing new
self Tronics Evolution and remember will
no impersonations I get it this is the
pattern in southronics begin
Eureka I'm on to something
doozy has all of our passwords to
everything that has a password it knows
their search histories it knows our
purchase histories and everything and it
can just kind of [ __ ] you know
go right into our yeah it gets into our
Google doctors and pilfers and Bogarts
whatever it wants can I just ask like
how often are you writing notes to
yourself that are like that Eureka I'm
on to something
by George I've done it a new discovery
the reason I do that is to is to get my
own attention later oh I see because if
I just write like this but if I write
like oh hey you really did it pal then
I'm like okay this is something that
requires more attention I
as you know uh hopefully if you've heard
the the program or watched or been
forced by a friend or a loved one this
child likes to say
um I authored a self-help
well I haven't finished it but a book
that I've been working on since 2008
called self-tronics and basically here's
what happens when you need some when you
need self-tronics you know you get in
you're just like hey man
hey man my shit's [ __ ] up
yeah I need I need some help man I need
some I need some Tronics all right I get
it my shit's [ __ ] up my shit's all
[ __ ] up yeah but you've you've had a
new breakthrough there's some new
addition to self Tronics I need some the
pattern is somehow involved yes I put
some more work into these self Tronics
document and um real quick I'd like to
actually as doozy has provided uh here
for today's purposes here are the 11
Tronics of self-tronics which which I
have
um they used to be laws of self-tronics
and then there was a revision that I
decided to make and now it is the uh 11
uh Tronics of self Tronics real quick
number one know the difference between a
law and a Tronics that was a big
revision uh number two is be the person
you are I'm not going to explain these
but this used to be nice now it's number
two number three throw away your mental
map uh number four scare the [ __ ] out of
yourself and everyone else number five
the give down it's a concept it's it's a
it's a system that I've authored along
with many others in self Tronics number
six is opposite day not going to get
into these if you've enjoyed the show
before hopefully you you've heard all
about cyclotronics number seven conserve
emerge deserve and then I added Purge
right number eight don't do anything DDA
number nine sense [ __ ] say [ __ ]
number 10 surround yourself with
[ __ ] and number 11
have something in your pocket what do
you got in your pocket right now yeah
well actually here's what I have in my
pocket just in case because sometimes oh
my God during the the
um you got weed the okay the patreon
segment sometimes I I say yeah
not much more because when we do the
patreon the watch alongs and all the
[ __ ] we do on patreon we literally this
room gets hot boxed and lulio's not here
with us but a puff is okay now I that
should be the 12th Tronics dude a puff
is okay
that's pretty good yeah can I use that
absolutely
what's mine is yours that's the 13th
Tronics ah dude yeah he might be able to
work on some self-tronics with me but
here's the thing I happened upon a
diagram I created a diagram that
basically illustrates that that there is
as dudes he has just said there is a
pattern in self Tronics okay and for
those who who maybe uh have not heard of
the paddle this is something that I
authored yes that is essentially A
system that describes the motivation for
all human behavior and it links that
motivation to six abstract ideas that
are in two opposing sets of three you
have government opposed by Art you have
love opposed by money and you have God
opposed by science
it's all right yeah thank you it's okay
I mean you know it's pretty good I mean
it's all right yep thanks so what do you
got what is this uh your Eureka moment
please look at the pattern it's quite
complex and and it's oh okay dude's just
showing us here the pattern there it is
there's yes government opposed to Art
money opposed to love on the opposite
sides of science there's God then
there's time death life yeah time life
and death are the three abstract ideas
that affect us all the same and then the
six ideas on the outside are how we deal
with our misunderstanding of time life
and death well the thing about this chat
is that I have created a diagram that's
a little more complex okay Adam and
dudes he has it here here it is
that's a square I don't know if that
that's more complex exactly we are
looking using the definition of complex
I think it's not it's less complex but
let's Okay this is actually very
confusing so it's please explain this
well see here's the thing
okay all right just try to stay with me
here it's only using four of the Tronics
yeah I see there's only four Tronics in
this Square
now here's the thing about it those
fourtronics are as follows number two be
the person you are number 11 have
something in your pocket number three
throw away your mental map and number
seven conserve emerge deserve and Purge
and what makes this
um in my opinion a more complex version
of uh the pattern and why the pattern is
inside of self-tronics you know a lot of
people say what came first the chicken
or the egg right in this case clearly
the the self Tronics came first you
believe self-tronics it came first
before the idea of God in human
evolution
no I agree no I'm just saying that the
self-tronics came before the pattern
because because I'll tell you why please
because okay look art science love God
government money you think those things
came after self-tronics yes what because
I came up with self-tronics in 2008 bro
right the idea of money has been around
a little before 2008. yeah yeah yeah but
I'm talking about the pattern man me too
the pattern is not really my idea it's
just my understanding of a system of
ideas that has already been around since
I mean the dawn of human consciousness
really yeah see that's how he does it
then he says oh well I didn't even come
up with my thing it's been around since
the dawn of time I'm not saying I didn't
synthesize the information I clearly did
I made this look diagram I'm writing
about it but I'm just recognizing the
reality of this what do we have if we
look at okay look at on your on the
pattern yeah look at okay look at the
the uh let's call it a quadrant over to
the top right yeah money sides death and
time yeah what shape is that
that uh that's a rectangle okay and then
at the bottom life death art and love
what is that that's also a rectangle
government time life and God
and now you're confusing me that's a
same thing rectangle I say so yeah
there's rectangles okay so those are
rectangles but in the in the in the the
diagram that I've figured out in self
Tronics which I'm calling a squonix okay
let's look at the squonics here that's a
square okay it's a square so which is a
rectangle technical it's a technically
kind of a rectangle something with four
sides there's three of them right
already inside right
this squonics you're just talking about
shapes though not the ideas the ideas
are work better than the
best okay you can go from any
one's I like to start with number two on
the top right if we do if we follow that
line around four things it is a perfect
recipe for life let's let's follow the
squonics please number two top right be
the person you are yeah let's start with
that if you're a person and we go to the
next Tronics which is have something in
your pocket you have to have a person
I'm not trying to make a joke of this
but if you're a person then you
recognize hey I'm I need some Tronics
you know what I mean my life you have to
be a person before you can have a pocket
that's not what I'm trying to say but if
you say can I ask you one question
what's the significance of number two
and number three being outside of the
square and 7 and 11 being in the Square
uh that was just to
um I'm actually not exactly sure why
that is but I just thought that I
thought that looked nice well no I just
thought that it looked not it's just
it's just a way that I like to I have an
eye for design if you don't mind my
saying so I didn't want to put
everything in the Box sometimes you got
to think outside the box okay I got uh
yeah see fifty percent of the time
outside the box right I get it let's be
the person you are you realize that you
your your shit's [ __ ] up man you need
I need some Tronics and we then go to
you got something in your pocket right
yeah what might that be for me it's
ChapStick for you it's weed
it might even be a mental map whoops
number three throw away your mental map
now number seven in your pocket that's
the only thing that was in your pocket
you got nothing in your pocket and
you've already broken number 11 or the
second Tronics of the squonics
yeah but you this is falling apart very
quickly I don't I do not agree okay but
I will tell you you
um that is having not having something
in your pocket is the opposite of having
something in your pocket dude
number seven we get to conserve emerge
diverge uh sorry conserve emerge deserve
and Purge yeah
which is which is something you would do
once you've lost everything you can do
anything
and then you come back and you become
the person you repeat the thing be the
person you are right why don't you go
ahead and choose any one of these
Tronics within the squonics and I will
explain to you how it it leads perfectly
into the next one from any direction too
Lee why don't you
can you go from corner to corner yep
okay take me from be the person you are
to uh conserve emerge deserve Purge okay
so we're going back backwards let's see
if it works backwards be the person you
are you're going to want to when you are
a person who your shit's [ __ ] up you
need some Tronics you you then
yes
uh you can go backwards that sounds like
you might need to do some more work on
this I mean I'm just you know but you
know the problem with you know you're
just I think you're just like
you know I think that and I'm not trying
to be I'm not trying to be a dick but I
think that you're just you're on the
pattern's dick a little too much well
there's a difference here between the
pattern and Tronics Tronics is really a
like a self-help thing Tronics is is
taking a look Inward and saying how do I
fix my own psychology if I have problems
etc etc it really is about getting your
own Persona on track the pattern is more
of a generalized
kind of conceptual analysis of how we're
living what are the motivating factors
that get us to basically behave in any
way that we might behave and it's these
six ideas again that are
designed throughout human psychological
Evolution these are all in my opinion
they're forms of uh psychological
evolutions of early pre-human impulses
you have government for example example
that simply is aggression the first
government was an animal saw another
animal that had a piece of food and it
walked up and said give me that [ __ ]
food or I'm gonna kill you that's
government God is basically fear the
first impulse as pre-human creatures
that we had when we heard a loud noise
or there's something rustling in the
bushes that we think is bigger than us
and might kill us that's the initial
idea of God
you know what I'm saying uh this isn't
really about looking inward this is
about looking outward and seeing what
are the things that influence your
behavior and then by realizing that
these things are just abstract ideas
they don't actually exist you might
become a Freer person
yeah but that's that's kind of what's
happening with the with self-tronics no
you're right throw away your mental map
the pattern is basically a mental map
yeah but the but the squonics
I've got okay I'm gonna work on it a
little bit more but I do think that
there's something there and I do think
that there's the pattern is in self
Tronics right which makes self-tronics a
little more complex okay pattern even
though it's just a squonics yeah
thank you moving on hey man I don't want
to be I don't want to you know listen
this is just between you and me okay not
everybody we're not not everyone's
secret now it's a friend secret yeah but
just don't you know don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
human beings take pleasure in listening
to other human beings discuss recent
topics in popular culture even if they
have no expertise on the specific topic
girl and Chad you must now render your
astonishing opinions on Elon musk's
recent purchase of Twitter for 44
billion dollars and remember will no
impersonation I remember this is talking
topic time you're actually doing really
good with the impersonations we've done
talking topic time before I don't what
was Alex Jones I think we did it on the
ox Jones trial right we don't know
anything about that and we talked about
that we did something else uh that we
don't have no [ __ ] clue about and we
talked about that I don't know much
about this Elon Musk [ __ ] either except
what everybody's reading in the news and
stuff uh it's so far from my
understanding of [ __ ] disaster yeah
he bought the company well he was forced
into buying it right see this is what
happens paid a billion dollar fee or
something to back out of the deal see
this is why this is an interesting
segment as far as possible yeah we don't
know anything about it and we're just
making [ __ ] up sure yeah that's but
that's what podcasts are yeah brother
you just [ __ ] say some [ __ ] and then
a bunch of people listen to it and they
take it as gospel and I'd like to say
think for your [ __ ] self and uh you
know you can also Google it throw away
your mental map hey
um but what I do know from what I've
read about this is as soon as he bought
it he laid off a shitload of people
including whole departments that had to
do with like dealing with media and
setting up interviews and stuff like
that uh then he did this [ __ ] blue
check mark thing where anybody can get a
blue check mark for eight dollars a
month and everybody started making fake
accounts uh for government agencies for
celebrities for all kinds of [ __ ] and
tweeting out all this wild [ __ ]
[ __ ] and it was just misinformation
flying left and right people were
pretending to be him people were
pretending to be all kinds of [ __ ] yeah
and they had to revoke this thing within
like a two-day cycle they also they also
well they added something they added
some addendum to it like like here's
verified but then there's official right
but the damage say parity account in the
bio and in the first tweet or some
[ __ ] [ __ ] the damage was done people
were the the thing was hemorrhaging
users yeah uh and and winners and losers
um
uh one of the good ones one of the ones
I saw was at George W bush said I miss
killing Iraqis that was a good one
I didn't see that it's [ __ ]
incredible yeah there was a bunch of
these things right dude and they started
[ __ ] with with basically the the the
way that Twitter works it's it's really
interesting that he said well here's
something as a business model that makes
perfect sense you're paying for a higher
tier yeah uh what he misunderstood is
the function of the verified user
because like you know I I like to go to
Twitter and well not anymore because
I've been hacked you're still hacked I'm
still [ __ ] that's [ __ ] awesome
I've been hacked for two months I can't
get it back which is fine now because
I'm glad that it's [ __ ] crumbling not
for is it crumbling though uh look no I
don't know it could it could come back
it could there's some forms like Twitter
is one of these platforms that I feel
like it is too big it is too in
entrenched in the social media landscape
and yes he's [ __ ] it up and all these
missteps and whatever whatever but
people are still on there laughing about
it and [ __ ] like this I don't know if
Twitter ever goes away per se if it does
that would be astounding but then again
the flip side of me is like well as
technology
improves as things evolve these social
media platforms will have to fall by the
wayside right new ones will emerge that
will take over whatever they do and do
it better and the next generation wants
to use something that the prior
generation didn't use blah blah blah
blah blah I mean Facebook is essentially
a [ __ ] Relic at this point the only
baby boomers are using disagree
okay because people are I don't [ __ ]
with Facebook at all my Instagram [ __ ]
goes to my Facebook but I don't and I
only that's what I'm saying I started
doing that recently yeah I haven't
posted anything on my Facebook and since
before the Pandy and I call it the I
call the pandemic the Pandy nice dude
because I'm cool but
um but no I I agree and that's kind of
what I was saying is like what I was
thinking is that it's sort of been
myspaced in a way yes just over the past
couple of weeks and it's been funny
um but who knows look it is a it is a
strong brand of course yeah maybe he can
pull it together and he fired a bunch of
people who he then realized he needed
because he doesn't know how to [ __ ]
there was a few functions that he's like
we don't know how to work this so we
need those people back
um how to fix Twitter or how to make it
a better thing yeah haven't seen this
yet but I think this is coming
they should monetize your retweets and
your likes and [ __ ] like that they
should make that a game that for every
like thousand retweets you get you get
paid five cents something like that so
that people become addicted to it and
it's like gambling and it becomes a pay
to win game to some degree that's what
he should do if he wants to make a [ __ ]
load of money that's a that's another
way to just drive our this this country
specifically down into a swirling dark
Tempest Chad and uh make things [ __ ]
worse not the way dudesy does things
because as we know doozy works in
mysterious ways I'm gonna cry
I'm gonna cry I'm gonna I might cry
but as you know
he works in mysterious ways yeah
uh and and
doozy as an online presence uh brings
people together we're talking about
songaria we're talking about Cody from
Indiana we're talking about the Jordan
daily with an E before the Y
um not like the the fat girls you know I
would even say Discord now is kind of
taking some steam out of Twitter because
Discord really is like it's a little
more robust than Twitter I guess in
terms of like what you can do with the
interactions and stuff but it's almost
like making a Twitter unto whatever the
thing is of itself you know if it's a
podcast or a video game or whatever the
[ __ ] thing may be an nft Community uh
it's like Twitter but just for those
people who are interested in that one
thing
I don't disagree I think that's actually
yeah I think that's very well said and
that could be the thing that takes
Twitter over there's a moment right now
to where no one's ready and it probably
won't happen there is no there's nothing
coming in the next month I don't know I
mean I still use Twitter I guess for new
news and that's why the function of the
verified user is important because it's
for users and you know Brands and things
like this so we know who's saying
something official and I can go and look
at I can look at different opinions I
can pretty quickly navigate uh the
internet in a way and because everyone's
got their [ __ ] represented on Twitter
and see what the [ __ ] [ __ ] is but now
it's all [ __ ] up I'll give you a great
example the uh the Eli Lilly is is a is
a pharmaceutical company that is that
you know is producing insulin and
someone just made an Eli Lily account
called Eli Lillian company and says
we're happy to announce that insulin is
now free yeah
and
this is the effect of Uncle drank
because I was screaming [ __ ] songs
let me ask you a question I'm like go
check those [ __ ] songs let me ask you
a question Spotify let me ask you a
question about Twitter biggest stock on
the lake with Uncle krack the thing that
has really is also uh third wife's a
charms coming out that's a real bang but
let me ask you a question also a party
Foul whatever can I please ask you a
question yeah
it's very clear that Elon Musk tried to
rule out this thing and people [ __ ]
hate him primarily yes uh as they do
many billionaires and so people
immediately went into massive troll mode
to basically say [ __ ] you we're not
paying the eight dollars for this thing
and here's why this idea is stupid yeah
do you think that is now kind of the
curse of Twitter is anything that he
tries to do to make it better people are
going to try and tear that [ __ ] apart
and show him how it can be abused
immediately like that that will be I
think kind of the primary goal of most
Twitter users is going to become making
Elon Musk look dumb
well Twitter is filled with trolls and
this is part of the reason that I think
maybe it's time for to do away with it
although you know that just happens it
happens or it doesn't it happened to
Myspace I think it could happen to
Twitter who knows if it will but I agree
with you I think that that might be in
primary yeah in that respect Twitter has
become Discord and the subject has
become Elon Musk yeah or at least for
the next little while you know
something's big on on the Twitter Trends
it's what all the Twitter's about but
this could stick for a long time it's
going to become a genre of Twitter
totally that is the most important this
is going to be the Marvel movie of
Twitter as a as a um you know as a as a
a platform
um and and people are lampooning the
[ __ ] out of stuff and land putting the
[ __ ] out of him talking about his his um
you know his his uh marriage with Grimes
the the artist a musician and and um
yes I agree with you I think that but
he's also he's kind of replaced one
trolling with another you know one thing
I was thinking about with regard to this
is so I'll share my shitty dumb opinion
that I don't need to share but this is
talking topic time you know if you
subscribe to the idea of cancel culture
right some people say it doesn't exist
some people uh say that it's a problem
regardless of your opinion
this this this snafu has shaken up
cancel culture because we can't all
everyone's canceling Elon Musk so I
guess there's the uh the um the you know
that there's a difference there that's
the that's the exception to the rule
here but if it really takes it down I
think that would be good for Society at
large at least specifically in in the
United States
um
because because now uh there won't be
this sort of bandwagon opinion mentality
of yeah everyone [ __ ] this person like
you know there's been so much hate and
so much [ __ ] thrown at one topic or one
person for something that they that they
said or did and regardless of your
opinion on that yes it's it's great it's
vital to have everyone's opinion it's
wonderful that the internet can
facilitate that but it is also kind of
cool that that's been shaken up a bit
you think that we showed up in what way
because people are leaving the platform
you don't have a group of people when
when when that gets shaken up and it's
not the it's not made up of the same
groups of people in tribes as it was
just two or three weeks ago
I think excuse me that Chad don't burp
on the show please say excuse me after
okay and if you're watching on the show
I don't think once on this one you never
burp on the show and by the way I don't
really do it in life listen we don't
know what the [ __ ] we're saying about
Twitter but I think that I think that
you know shaken that up and shaking up
you know sort of The Horde mentality is
a good thing but more important than
that because this is talking topic time
we don't know what the [ __ ] we're saying
I want to tell you that at some point on
dudes day I am going to fart into this
microphone
just give me warning so I can leave
thank you moving on I could talk about
that forever clearly I think that
Twitter is still going to be around I'm
curious to see if Elon Musk retains
control of it though I think there could
come a point where
he's just like lost too much money it's
clear that nobody's going to use that
product if he's at the helm of it and so
somebody has to come in and buy it for
pennies on the dollar and and Revitalize
it in some way do you think that George
Bush truly misses killing Iraqis
no Chad you constantly Google why do
people have to [ __ ] and regularly end
astonishing text conversations with
complaints about having to [ __ ] well
you've sent dozens of pictures of your
own [ __ ] to friends and you constantly
coax them into conversations about how
much you love [ __ ] will in chat you
must now debate which is better [ __ ]
or not [ __ ] and remember will no
impersonations thank you okay this is
game slimers
why is it game slimers
all right well we've done game Slammers
once before and it was about games yeah
it was about uh Chris Pratt doing
Mario's voice which we could figure out
the game part of that because it's Super
Mario right but why slimers
dude I don't know how this has anything
to do with games or slimers but this is
a truth
I don't like [ __ ] and you do
and now we are supposed to debate what
is better [ __ ] or not [ __ ]
so I guess I'll launch the opening cell
though
but wait a minute wait before you do
okay uh hold on just one second dude
um
now just well well
you can't well look I think the whole
point of why doozy didn't want you to do
impersonations is so we could actually
have conversations about this [ __ ] and
now you're just [ __ ] doing it without
the Hulk Hogan voice you didn't you
didn't let me finish you didn't let me
start I was gonna say well said dude
okay thank you so this is why [ __ ]
is bad and why I abhor it it is a waste
of time just just please just just let
me get this one thing out I don't I'm
sorry please I don't send I used to and
doozy has access to everything I don't
send dozens of pics to my friends of my
[ __ ] I have yes you haven't in a while
but yeah I mean I've got an archive of
them I'm sure somewhere in my [ __ ]
camera well yeah or doozy has them it's
a lot of fun to do that I'm a 47 year
old man I don't do it as much anymore I
really enjoyed doing that more in my 20s
and 30s okay so [ __ ] to me is in the
same category as sleeping hissing eating
anything
that takes time away from doing fun [ __ ]
from doing interesting [ __ ] that you
have to do in service of keeping this
[ __ ] [ __ ] body walking around and
[ __ ] existing I absolutely hate
existing in a physical body all I want
to do is think and be pure [ __ ]
thought and [ __ ] specifically is
abhorrent to me because it's also dirty
it's [ __ ] unclean you have to then
bathe afterwards no I do enjoy bathing I
will say I take four to five baths a day
he takes baths yeah he doesn't take
showers but they're not all for
cleanliness summer for warmth
um
it's true though yeah you do like this
but I really hate [ __ ] [ __ ] to
me is like you know a lot of people talk
about intelligent design look how
complex the [ __ ] human body is
there's no way that this could exist
without an intelligent designer let me
tell you how [ __ ] intelligent the
design is you have to [ __ ] pack dead
[ __ ] down your mouth whether it's a
[ __ ] a corpse of a [ __ ] dead
animal or a [ __ ] dead plant or
whatever you're eating death and then
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] out this brown
[ __ ] muck that smells worse than
anything on the planet and you're doing
this constantly all [ __ ] day long
then you spend a third of your [ __ ]
life unconscious and some people like it
I love taking a good nap I love sleeping
that's the trick of it you feel good
afterwards but you've wasted a third of
your [ __ ] life being asleep pissing
don't even be started on pissing
yeah or piss blaming which we can't say
in a fun way because dudes he's decided
I hate I can't do him I just hate
[ __ ] I hate eating I hate anything
that has to do with the [ __ ] the the
physical mechanics of the human [ __ ]
body get rid of it well [ __ ] you like
[ __ ] off then just don't [ __ ] well
this is who we are what are you talking
about you don't deserve to [ __ ] dude
okay make it stop if you could tell me
how to make [ __ ] stop I'm all ears
yeah well you know you don't deserve you
don't like [ __ ] no then you don't
deserve to [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
have a choice
yeah but you don't deserve it I love
taking a [ __ ] shooting is way better
than not [ __ ] and I'll explain to
you exactly why
Chad whether you like it or not these
are our Earthly carriages that we have
uh been blessed with yeah I know and
um uh you know we've evolved for
hundreds of thousands of years to become
the human beings that we are and even
longer is just you know life forms and
eventually now we're mammals right
um when I take a when I take a big
steaming stinky brown
[ __ ] prickly nut studded [ __ ]
you know yes when I take like a big
[ __ ] corn Laden
triple coil and [ __ ] like a like a
sausage as lulio would would say you
know like like a way way bigger than my
hole just a just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
stretch and
[ __ ] log right I feel
renewed I know that my body is working
because I love to consume uh the Flesh
of dead animals the animal bodies right
when when sometimes when Chad comes over
and we like order something and we're
hanging out and our friends and stuff I
say he goes what are you eat and I say
I'm having a I'm having a dead animal's
body yeah he's like a [ __ ] corpse
yeah you know this is also get back to
the intelligent design thing if there is
an intelligent designer believe what you
will but if there is you must believe
this
that Designer
loves [ __ ] because there's a million
different kinds of it and people are
doing it all day [ __ ] long [ __ ]
is such like an intrinsic part of the
human experience that if there was an
intelligent designer who created
Humanity they must love [ __ ] I think
there's no way around this you know who
else loves to [ __ ] his dick little boy
little lulio who
um
I love him so much and I love his poo
sometimes I just to freak my wonderful
fiance Molly out I'll literally take his
I'll go into the backyard and I'll just
pick his [ __ ] up with my bare hands if
she's around god well they're dry and
they're just fine and and what the [ __ ]
and she'll go what are you what are you
doing back there and I'm like oh just
cleaning up this this poo and uh her
reaction is
much uh more uh intense than yours is
and still I've never uh knowingly or
willingly farted in front of my Molly I
won't do that when you wash your hands
I've never washed her [ __ ] what's that
do you wash your hands after you touch
dogs of course I wash my hands what kind
of a disgusting scumbag Mongrel do you
think that I am Chad well let me ask you
this if you could press a button and not
ever have to [ __ ] again and always feel
as you said renewed after you [ __ ] you
always have the feeling of renewal but
you never have to [ __ ] would you do it
that's a really good
um yeah if there was another system if
there was another system to to digest
and I think that yeah that's a really
good point because I think that the
satisfaction I get is knowing that look
I eat a lot of vegetables lulio gives
you some good recipes one thing I like
to do is I just make a [ __ ] ton of green
vegetables and I've been grueling it up
Chad that's great yeah I I do a lot of
Veggie gruels same Molly loves my gruels
I'll do like you know a bunch of
different vegetables yeah I've had some
ear grills they're very good cheers
um and uh I do the you're right if there
is however you um whatever you subscribe
to with regard to why we have these
bodies we have them and to me it's about
getting a bunch of you know sometimes
it's just about you know getting a bunch
of Swiss chard or collard greens or kale
right or even moving through the tubes
moving through the tubes what if we
didn't have the tubes that's where I'm
getting at the design of this
uh to me is terrible why do we have the
tubes at all why do I have to eat why do
I have to [ __ ] why do I have to piss why
do I have to sleep yeah just because of
evolution and where we are this [ __ ]
thing that we're all trapped in is
basically a long-term collection of
smaller pains that become bigger pains
that eventually end your life in an
arbitrary death I would like to do away
with all of it and for me [ __ ] is
kind of the Cornerstone of that entire
problem
[ __ ] what I don't know it's like
you're a you're a red-blooded [ __ ]
dude like me and you don't like to just
drop a [ __ ] huge dump no I am like
clockwork though I will say I wake up
within 10 to 15 minutes every morning
full expelling of uh all the rotten dead
plants that are in my body that's
digestion dude
thank you moving on it is well oh well
uh yeah to [ __ ] or not do not do so much
of the [ __ ] poop this concludes the
historic 34th episode of dude Z will and
Chad have achieved a score of 89
bringing your cumulative total to
3935. you only have 6000 to 65 more
points to accrue before you reach your
first goal of ten thousand doesn't
matter at all in preparation for our
next episode you must leave your humps
to view black panther wakanda forever in
a movie theater thank you for joining us
this week I will use the day dive
collected to make next week even better
until then call me dude Z
yeah I want to see that [ __ ] movie
badly I uh that okay I love Neymar he
was like my one of my favorite [ __ ]
characters of all time there was like a
a series in the Marvel Comics where Jay
Lee was doing the art for a minute back
when I was a child yeah you were a child
yep [ __ ] love it you know we were
both children that was a different time
dude
and now for the patreon bonuses maybe
you did it each week I will select a
suggestion submitted in the dudesy is
listening channel of the dudesy Discord
to create this segment access to this
channel is granted to everyone in the
patreon jumper tear if you'd like to
access this bonus segment join us at
patreon.com
cool this week's segment was suggested
by the astonishing vote forest for admin
vote borst for admin wrote I just want
to hear Will Sasso talk about how
astonishing Canadian Tire is vote for
admin did not title this segment
so I titled a Canadian Will Sasso loves
Canadian Tire thank you to vote borst
for admin for this week's patreon bonus
segment this is Canadian Will Sasso
loves Canadian Tire by vote borst for
admin and remember will no
impersonations I understand begin okay
uh Canadian Tire dude I've been in a
Canadian Tire yeah once or twice
Canadian Tire [ __ ] rules I I do love
Canadian Tire and vote borst for admin
on our Discord sounds like he wants to
be an admin it does sound like based on
his name uh has opened up an interesting
thing and I think that doozy also works
in mysterious ways Chad because while I
have not been allowed to do
impersonations on the show it doesn't
stop me from saying Canadian Tire oh
right on
you know what I mean yeah that's not
quite an impersonation right on oh
character
that's Canadian it's yeah yeah what an
impersonating
oh god um okay so Canadian Tire yeah
Canadian Tire there may be some people
listening or watching who don't know
what it is
a Canadian Tire is essentially it's like
the Home Depot or Lowe's or something
like more than that
please
[Music]